what's the risk of injury of a drone
impact occurs that causes a human tissue
damage it's a serious brain injury or or
fatal event here at Virginia Tech the
world's largest injury biomechanics
program so we do a lot of research and
brain injury and concussion and skull
fracture the connection between helmets
and drone is it's all about head injury
risk that's what we have is the hybrid
three test dummy this was developed over
decades for the auto industry it's the
same dummy that's used to certify your
car we'll use that to get an idea of the
interaction between the drone and a
human so the aircraft are flown
horizontally at maximum speed
square with the test dummies head we
have a separation of molded plastic
party once the impact occurs there's
data gathered from numerous
accelerometers which measure the
g-forces we look at quantifying injury
risk we typically look at two measures
accelerations and loads so we can take
those accelerations we take the force
value so we can compare those two other
research we've done for auto safety and
for military and that's how we determine
injury risk if you look at cars and
automobile safety we put an incredible
amount of work and effort in design and
making sure they're safe we're hoping to
have the same sort of analysis for
drones do you have some sort of
parachute advice that slows the kinetic
energy frangible if it's not rigid and
breaks apart on impact that's going to
reduce the energy transfer
do you add padding blade protectors it's
a lot of things we need to better
understand to help the industry make
safer drone and that's the goal to
research
[Music]
[Music]
you